with terrifying speed an avalanche can
rumble down a mountain slope burying
everything in its path under a lethal
blanket of snow
each year about 150 people in europe and
north america
die from avalanches
large ones can wipe out forests and
erase mountain villages
avalanches come in many forms some
called sluff consist of sliding loose
snow
[Music]
others called slab avalanches occur when
large sections of the snow pack crack
off and crash down the slope
as snow falls it builds up layer upon
layer
with enough time the layers will harden
and bond to one another
but when layers form weak bonds any new
snow falls on an unstable foundation
and waits for the right trigger
avalanches are caused by sudden changes
a heavy snowfall strong winds or a rapid
change in temperature
the shape and angle of the slope are
important factors slopes over 60 degrees
are usually too steep
slopes under 25 degrees are too gentle
the danger zone comes between 30 and 45
degrees just where people like to ski
and sled
90 of avalanche victims die because they
or someone with them accidentally
trigger an avalanche
contrary to popular opinion loud noises
like yelling won't trigger an avalanche
in most cases it's the sudden weight of
a skier or snowmobiling that makes the
surface unstable
then the avalanche descends at speeds up
to 80 miles an hour
as winter sports become more popular
avalanches pose more of a threat
ski patrols now monitor popular slopes
to prevent avalanches from ever
happening
cannons fire explosives that slam into
snow bats to trigger small avalanches
before the buildup becomes a problem
[Music]
search and rescue teams practice
locating and digging out people trapped
underneath the snow
but ultimately it's up to every person
to watch out when they're on the slope
so pay attention to the weather look for
warning signs
learn what to do in an emergency
because everything can change in just a
few seconds
you